[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space okay we're jumping
through this puzzle the right way I
don't even know I'm so upside down right
yes thank you
okay I'm back in the beginning I killed
another one of those doodad monsters and
I don't know how many are left I only
think I've put three on this level maybe
I don't know I don't trust you don't
trust you that would probably be a very
terrible death to get pulled into one of
those holes and probably like flailing
you get pulled in sideways crack okay
making our way slowly through the gate
okay I don't need to say I'm too hard
roads
I heard a blub blub will be beloved go
down sure I'll go down one now are you
gonna be some monsters waiting for me
now they know better they know better
she's scared of me okay
I heard that
[Applause]
give me more no not that take a head
take this to and take out quick to the
back because you don't have a face
anymore I was gonna say for this okay I
wonder why
what kind of alien is this that it's
weakness is having its limbs cut off
that's a very strange weakness because
it's brain like spread out throughout
its body or something
whoa that's just gross why didn't they
give the other people seats like this I
think that qualifies a hallucination
auditory hallucination there's a
scientific word for that but I don't
remember what it is
alright don't need two larges don't need
two mediums get out your plan manatee
don't need you no need you horse energy
no playing this game card for war life
yes gimme okay I'm good on arrow
and versus but no Pepsi boy there's no
way that's gonna last I mean it's not
even a permanent solution if an entire
ship couldn't clean it out then this
isn't gonna work
haha how is one guy able to fix it I
mean all these guns he found on the ship
so the other guys just sucked
they weren't me they didn't have me
controlling him that's probably yep
Ariel oh I thought that was another one
of those gas monsters I generate Oh
everywhere dr. Krauss that's how she was
dead it's hard for me to believe what
I'm seeing here this is crazy absolutely
crazy I'm going to some mining deck I'll
wait for you there yeah take it fries no
absolutely that's temple I think that's
David beat him poison
[Music]
bah-bah oh so sad alright do it
did I win there and kill it before it
contaminates the entire ship okay yeah
[ __ ] oh it's a body oh that's a bigoted
bigoted Wow oh oh
goodies everywhere probably loading me
up for fighting this guy probably yep
that's a head solid oh why did the head
explode okay they giving me lots of fire
sticks so let's start it up what that
didn't bug yeah did I just waste a fire
sick
I a big yellow weak point
hey don't do that
you f write-off oh you own some come on
buddy
what the hell
but there it is
it's not jumping Oh George oh there were
a bunch of them there oh what Oh what
you can't handle none of this
yeah before you got a chance oh I see it
that's secretive never baby
there we go
ah
I know they're back they're back oh no
am I out of fire aah
I get that
you know please open up
ah yeah whoa hold you hardcore yeah oh
yeah oh you could whoa hey whoa back off
buddy do you read oxygen levels are
returning to normal I am and buddy damn
it he's gone again knows rig anywhere
it's up to us now I've got a plan to get
off the ship I've located an SOS beacon
on the mining deck if you can get down
there and activate it we might be able
to send a distress call yeah yeah
whatever you're probably fine it'll hold
as long as until I get there then it'll
break okay so what was that about a
mining deck hey there are items
everywhere I love it it's hard to see
them in here
they're just like so static did you not
give me an item or is this technically
you're giving me an item you're not
gonna give me like a power node or a
rubies semiconductor maybe you just
that's a goodbye present fine whatever I
was an event that was a very good
implementation of zero-gravity I'd like
that battle that was a very cool boss
battle and I like having boss battles I
like games that put in boss bats most of
the new games that just come by activate
most of games that come by that are
newer just feature your the end game is
not a boss it's nothing it's just
another enemy and you gonna kill a
certain number of them until you get to
the last guy who's no tougher than
anyone else
and at least in games like this the
pause is gigantic and that's what the
end boss is supposed to be it's supposed
to be huge yeah mmm love it love it love
it
I'm in love in this game in case you
didn't notice all right yeah so need you
don't need you don't need to tell me all
oh wow you said that I didn't ignore you
I know I have a safe now but I'm so pro
I don't need it so give me some more
power nose hell yeah seven so pro look
at me go
I should crank it up too hard can I can
I change the difficulties look hard can
I don't know if I could I would this is
70 it hasn't even been a little bit of a
challenge I do need a help though there
we go
all better oh that's like a third health
kit I've ever used back down
yay I guess that's
down we go
this is the world's longest elevator why
such long elevators the game doesn't
need to put in these it's not like they
actually needed to put the level that
much higher than the other one but
whatever I'm not done I really like that
pwned him so hardcore
Oh
all right who's out here Oh who's out
there someone in there oh this is that
bathroom again I'm not going in there
I'm gonna assume that no wait a minute
whoa where are the bodies what who's
taking all the bodies what how where are
they going
this is messed up okay they must just be
turning them into more of the doodads
okay anyway that's that done yay
environmental hazard go save yes please
all right good on that into the void
that sounds good
oh the mining deck looks gigantic yeah
hydroponics was pretty small but if it
actually it was pretty big when I look
to think about the level design but it
was just that itty bitty speck on the
ship and mining deck looks huge
right well the mining deck is gonna have
to wait until the next episode thank you
guys so much for watching and I will see
you in the next part bye-bye